It’s been 4 months since the 2018 iPad Pro
was released and many of you have been holding
off on buying one.
Maybe it’s just too expensive and you’re
waiting for it to go on sale, or maybe you’ve
heard some good things and some bad things
about the new iPad Pro, and you’re waiting
to hear if the iPad experience is actually
improved in the real world compared to an
old iPad or iPad Pro.
So let’s talk about my personal experience
with some of the best and most controversial
features as well as some of the drawbacks
of the new iPad Pro after 4 months of use.
First off, it feels like no iPad you’ve
ever used before.
Even the 2017 iPad Pro doesn’t come close
in terms of design.
The displays all-new rounded corners make
it feel like a part of the future.
And after spending 4 months with it, I don’t
think I could ever go back to a Touch ID packing
iPad.
Face ID works better than on any iPhone, since
it works in literally any orientation, even
upside down.
After a while, you sort of forget that Face
ID is even there, since there’s no notch
at all, so it seems to work like magic.
Some people refuse to buy it because of the
lack of Touch ID, but Face ID works flawlessly,
trust me, you won’t miss it.
The 4-speaker stereo system sounds incredible,
just like it did on the last iPad Pro. iPads
with only one set of speakers on the bottom
simply can’t compare.
Seriously, guys, every aspect of the iPad
Pro’s design has been perfected, from the
Apple Pencil 2 and the new smart keyboard,
which I’ll talk about in a minute, everything
is finally perfect.
In my opinion.
For others, not so much.
Let’s get into some of the controversial
changes and what I think about them.
The biggest one is the removal of the headphone
jack.
I personally don’t care at all since I haven’t
even laid my hands on a set of wired earbuds
in over 2 years, ever since I got my AirPods.
And they’re so great that I can never go
back.
Of course, I understand that not everyone
has AirPods, but if you can afford this iPad
Pro, I’m pretty sure you can afford AirPods
and trust me, you won’t regret your purchase.
For everyone else, Apple sells a super cheap
$9 adapter on their website.
It’s a bit inconvenient, but it does the
job.
Now let’s talk about bendgate.
After 4 months of use, this iPad Pro is still
perfectly flat, and I’m pretty sure that
most people won’t experience any issues
at all.
However, a small percentage probably will,
especially those who aren’t very careful
with their stuff.
I honestly think the issue is just way overexaggerated
thanks to all the bend test videos on youtube.
USB-C is awesome, but it honestly doesn’t
make the iPad Pro any more of a computer than
the 2017 Pro.
The file manager sucks and you can’t connect
and edit files directly from an external storage
drive.
The reality of the whole computer dilemma
is that most people are just going to be doing
things like watching movies, using the pencil,
using apps, playing games, and doing business
or school work.
And for those people, the limitations of USB-C
on the iPad Pro really won’t matter.
My favorite part about USB-C is that you can
use your MacBook charging cable to charge
it, freeing up a wall plug.
A lot of people complained that the new iPad
Pro still doesn’t have an OLED display,
but it’ll drive up the price ever higher
since Apple is currently reliant on Samsung
for OLED displays, and Apple would also have
to ditch the iPad Pro’s ProMotion technology,
which doubles the display’s refresh rate
to 120hz for buttery smooth interactions,
including drastically reducing Apple Pencil
lag, so don’t expect to get OLED until Apple
can find a way to get ProMotion on an OLED
display.
Speaking of the Apple Pencil, its new method
of wireless charging makes the old Apple Pencil
seem like an unfinished product.
The new Apple Pencil feels solid and perfected,
especially thanks to its new double-tap feature,
which seriously makes a world of a difference
in terms of productivity.
The new smart keyboard folio is now completely
flat and smooth on both sides so it now looks
incredible compared to the old humpback keyboard,
and it also offers protection for the display
as well.
There are some downsides like being able to
feel the keys when the folio is folded back
and not being able to prop the display up
in theatre mode, but that doesn’t bother
me personally.
Finally, let’s talk about performance.
Many of you already know that the 2018 iPad
Pro packs the most powerful mobile chip ever,
but what you don’t know is if it really
matters.
After using it for 4 months, it’s hard to
tell much of a difference between this and
last year’s iPad Pro, even though it doubled
many benchmark scores.
For many years, iOS software developers have
been creating apps and games that can be run
on much weaker devices to support more of
the market, and the new iPad Pro’s performance
truly took everyone by surprise.
We simply don’t have very many apps and
games that can use even half of the potential
of the iPad Pro.
And at this rate, we’re gonna be waiting
a year or more until we start seeing a lot
of apps and games that’ll be limited by
the performance of, let’s say, the 2018
iPad and it’s A10 chip.
If you guys watched our 1-year review of the
regular iPad, you’d know that it’s good
enough for most people.
If you are one of those people who can take
advantage of the performance, definitely buy
it over the regular iPad or even the 2017
iPad Pro.
And of course, there are a lot of people who
don’t actually need all of that performance.
They just want the best that Apple has to
offer and they’re okay dishing out the cash
for it.
Now if you’re somewhere in the middle.
I’d say that after spending 4 months with
the new iPad Pro, just all of the design updates
alone without considering the massive performance
are worth paying some extra cash over the
2017 iPad Pro or any high-end Android tablet.
You’ve gotta think about the future, and
it’s much better to have all of that powerful
hardware right now and wait for the software
side to catch up than not have it when you’ll
eventually really need it.
This has been Vadim with Max Tech.
If you enjoyed the review, make sure to click
that like button while you’re heading to
the sub button.
We’ll see you in the next one!